[Music]
the movie is set in the 17th century
where france is under the rule of king
louis xiv the city of paris is in a
state of turmoil as most of the
population is either starving or sent to
war this has caused a huge uproar in the
city and riots are in full swing however
instead of fulfilling their demands the
king locks the riders in dilapidated
prisons where they are left to die a
slow and painful death among them is an
unknown man who is known by the nickname
the man in the iron mask in the next
scene the leader of the royal musketeers
group d'artagnan inspects the city on
his horse unfortunately he is quickly
pelted with rocks as he works for the
king turns out that there were four
popular musketeers in the past but only
d'artagnan remains loyal to the king now
as for the other three musketeers aramis
has become a reverend porthos has become
a drunkard who only cares about women
and ethos has retired to his farm as
porthos and aramis live together they
often quarrel because of their
contrasting lifestyles one day while
they are at it they are visited by
d'artagnan who informs the duo that the
king wants to see them elsewhere ethos
hands his son raul his wife's ring so
that he can propose to his girlfriend
turns out that ethos's wife died long
ago and his son wants to become a
musketeer just like him the scene then
cuts to the royal palace where the king
is briefing his generals about an
upcoming war just then one of his
consultants pierre informs him about the
riots in the city he also suggests they
distribute the food from the army
reserves so that the riots will stop
however king louis orders him to
distribute rotten food instead meanwhile
aramis arrives at the palace and the
king welcomes him warmly the king then
orders aramis to find the leader of the
jesuits who has been causing civil
unrest not only that he also orders the
former musketeer to eliminate the
so-called traitor in the name of god and
france aramis is hesitant about the plan
but he has no choice but to agree
meanwhile a special occasion is about to
take place inside the palace and several
people have arrived to be a part of it
among the crowd raul is with his
girlfriend christine as the duo is
walking the king spots christine from
afar and gets smitten by her instantly
he then organizes a game and separates
raul from his girlfriend just as he is
about to propose as everyone is busy
with the game the king draws christine
near his palace and tries getting close
to her however christine lets him know
that she is faithful to raul despite
this the king attempts to kiss her but
just then they are distracted by a
dartanian who has been watching them
closely from nearby suddenly a jesuit
spy comes running to assassinate king
louis but dartanian manages to eliminate
him with his insane sword throw the king
is taken aback by the incident while
raul quickly takes christine away that
night dartanian finds out that raoul has
withdrawn his application from the royal
musketeer selection confused he visits
ethos to find out the truth but the
latter is also oblivious soon raul
arrives dejected and informs the duo
that he couldn't propose to christine
and now he has been drafted for war
against the dutch this enrages ethos who
suspects the greedy king of sending away
his son so that he can have christine
all to himself d'artagnan also feels
sorry for the young man and assures
ethos that he will speak to the king in
the next scene a horde of rioters attack
the palace for distributing rotten food
as things get out of control the
musketeers get ready to fire at the
rioters however d'artagnan stops them
from doing so and confronts the angry
mob all alone he then flexes some of his
sword moves and gains the crowd's trust
after this he vows to everyone that he
will get them food soon and hearing this
everyone disperses in an orderly manner
later he enters a secret passage inside
the palace and informs the king that
fresh food has to be delivered to the
mob d'artagnan also asks the king about
his intentions with christine but the
latter becomes unruly and replies that
he can do whatever he pleases since he
is the king elsewhere raul and his group
are preparing to invade the enemy's
territory but before advancing he hands
over a letter to another general
requesting him to deliver it to the
royal palace soon he leads the charge
but unfortunately a dutch cannon
explodes near him killing him instantly
the news of his death quickly reaches
christine and his father and both of
them break down in tears however ethos
develops a rage for vengeance and he
heads to the palace to confront the king
on reaching he takes down several
musketeers alone but dartanian quickly
subdues him he then pleads with his
friend to calm down so that he doesn't
suffer the same fate his son did ethos
agrees to walk away but he vows to take
revenge against the king before leaving
he also calls dartanian a traitor for
protecting his son's killer inside the
palace king louis arranges a lavish
dinner for christine but she can't pull
herself together to enjoy the meal as
she still mourns her lover's death
however louie assures her that all he
wants is her happiness he then takes her
to a private room and the duos start
making out meanwhile aramis gathers his
old musketeer friends inside the
catacombs of paris and briefs them about
his secret mission he reveals that king
louis has assigned him to track down and
eliminate the jesuit leader before he
can cause any more riots however the
only problem is that he is the jesuit
leader himself the revelation stuns his
friends but athos and porthos quickly
agree to support his plans on the
contrary dartanian refuses to help them
as he is loyal to the king hearing this
ethos bursts in anger and confronts
dartanian that if they ever cross paths
again he will not hesitate to kill in
the next scene we are taken to the
prison of bastille where the man in the
iron mask is peeking at the open sky
wondering when he'll be out meanwhile
the three musketeer friends arrive there
on a boat disguised as foreigners aramis
pretends to be a priest and he manages
to enter the prisoner's cell to read his
monthly prayers turns out that he's
carrying a corpse who's wearing an iron
mask similar to that of the prisoner
aramis then hides the boy inside his
body and calls out to the guards telling
them that the prisoner died of a plague
virus scared the guards immediately
burned the corpse leaving no trace
behind following this the group
carefully escapes the place and reaches
a countryside house there they clean up
the prisoner and in a shocking turn of
events he is revealed to be king louie's
twin brother philippe philippe mentions
that he used to live peacefully in a
farm but one day some soldiers
forcefully took him away to a prison and
confined him to a mask later aramis
finally reveals the truth to him turns
out that after his mother anne gave
birth to the twins their father king
louis xiii decided to discard one's son
to avoid any territorial conflicts
between them as a result felipe was
hidden far away in the prison of
bastille only on his death day the king
revealed it to his wife and to his other
son king louis xiv and desperately tried
to bring her son back but the greedy
king made sure his twin brother would
never see the light again by concealing
his face with an iron mask moreover
aramis reveals that he was the one who
put the mask on philippe he is sorry for
the atrocities felipe has been through
and vows to restore his birthright by
replacing him with king louie however
his friends are skeptical about the plan
as they think it is too dangerous back
in the palace king louis gets a message
informing his twins death but he is
unconcerned by it he then asks his men
to deliver the news to his mother and
opens another box there he finds the
iron mask and is taken aback meanwhile
after getting the news anne breaks down
in tears but dartanian approaches and
consoles her here it is revealed that
they had a romantic affair before
dartanian chose to become loyal to the
king elsewhere in the countryside the
three friends try to convince felipe to
be a part of their plan but he refuses
he claims that he doesn't want to
pretend to be someone else and wants to
live his life free however he agrees
when the musketeers share their dream of
a unified france where all the people
can live peacefully following this the
three start teaching felipe on how to
act like a king and they practice day
and night meanwhile as christine finally
starts getting used to the royalty of
the palace she suddenly gets the letter
that raul had sent her before dying
there raul has predicted his death and
also mentioned that he forgives her for
being with the king the letter
devastates christine and she realizes
that the king orchestrated her lover's
death elsewhere aramis meets anne at a
confessional and mentions that philippe
is alive in the next scene the royal
palace is hosting a masquerade ball
where hundreds of noble people are
dancing elegantly aramis ethos porthos
and philippe also arrive disguised in
fancy costumes when the king joins the
crowd to dance he starts seeing several
people with iron masks making him dizzy
turns out that the musketeers had
planned it all along when the king
enters his room the group takes the
opportunity and sneaks inside from the
secret entrance there aramus confronts
the king and knocks him unconscious when
he wakes up he finds his brother
philippe dressed like the king before he
can call for help he is gagged and
covered by porthos while felipe
nervously leaves the room to confront
the crowd outside as felipe sits on the
throne for the first time christine
suddenly confronts him and calls him a
killer however instead of apprehending
her like louis normally would he calms
her down by promising to make things
right again this surprises the crowd and
dartanian also begins to suspect him he
then orders the guards to be on high
alert and escorts philippe to the
underground dock downstairs the three
musketeers along with louie make their
way to the port where their boat awaits
suddenly they are spotted by the guards
and a lengthy tussle ensues despite
being outnumbered the three musketeers
show exemplary fighting skills and
manage to swat away the bad guys however
as they are about to escape the door
closes and they are caught by the guards
led by dartanian the friends have an
intense face off but just then ethos
uncovers king louie's face and threatens
to kill him d'artagnan is shocked by the
imposter and he orders his guards to
open the gate following this the two
groups trade the boys and as the
musketeers are about to depart with
philippe the guards again recapture him
forcing ethos porthos and aramis to flee
alone inside the palace king louis
stares at philippe angrily and reveals
to d'artagnan that the boy is not an
imposter but his own brother hearing
this dartanian is taken aback just then
anne enters the room and both she and
dartanian start begging the king to
pardon philippe despite all this the
greedy king orders his men to throw
felipe in the same prison with the same
mask over his face later as dartanian is
trying to console anne he suddenly hears
a scream from the other room on reaching
there he finds out that christine has
committed the unthinkable dartanian
becomes devastated but louis couldn't
care less about it elsewhere felipe is
fitted with the iron mask again and the
special key is handed over to king louie
meanwhile the three musketeers somehow
evade the guards and enter a room where
they find a note left by dartanian it
writes that he has arranged a 10-minute
window for them with the help of which
they can save philippe at first the trio
assumes it to be a trap but after much
consideration they conclude that their
old friend would never betray them hence
they suit up in their famous musketeer
costume and head to the said location to
save philippe in the next scene the trio
meets tartanian at a prison and together
they manage to find felipe as they try
to escape louis along with his men block
all the entrances left with no way out
the four musketeers bring back the old
days and start battling against louie's
men despite being outnumbered they use
their impressive skills and subdue the
soldiers however more men arrive and the
musketeers along with philippe are
forced to escape to another room there
felipe requests that the group give him
up so that they can be spared but
tartanian reveals that he could never
give up his son here it is revealed that
both louis and felipe were born to
dartanian and anne while they were
having an affair meanwhile louis asks
the group to surrender but much to his
surprise the musketeers charge at them
with tremendous courage even louise
guards are left in awe of their valor so
they hold back their weapons in respect
seeing this king louis becomes enraged
and swings a dagger at philippe but
d'artagnan gets in the way and takes the
hit sadly he passes away among his
friends sons and army generals philippe
is left devastated but soon he swaps
clothes with his brother and puts him in
an iron mask he then orders the guards
to take the imposter away and announces
that aramis athos and porthos are his
new royal advisors in the final scene of
the movie king philippe disguised as
king louis xiv along with the three
musketeers attend d'artagnan's funeral
there philippe approaches ethos and
expresses his desire to be his son and
the latter gladly agrees the movie ends
as it is revealed that after philippe
took over france became a prosperous and
powerful nation subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching